nayda alvarez vie au texas sur la terre
familiale le long du rio grande et
depuis 40 ans presque tous les jours
elle se rend au bord du fleuve qui
sépare les états unis du mexique un coin
de paradis dit elle dont elle ne
pourrait se passer
elle est en colère contre le président
chain nayda affirme n'avoir jamais vu
d'immigrants illégaux traversé son
terrain décideurs se pose le
gouvernement fédéral la menace diriger
une partie du mur à trois mètres de sa
maison
neid a leur a fait comprendre qu'elle ne
voulait rien savoir de leurs murs
le message pain en toutes lettres sur le
toit et sans équivoque
à une centaine de kilomètres de là à
brownsville le mur traverse déjà les
cours arrière de résidents une clôture
construite à l'époque des présidents
bush et obama une phase initiale possède
une maison près de la frontière le mur
passe dans sa cour arrière
le seul problème selon l'amf à des
espaces béants dans cette barrière
permettent aux clandestins de passer des
ouvertures nécessaires pour le travail
agricole peu de texans accepte homme
d'une femme la présence de cette immense
structure sur leur propriété
havas l'état ne veut pas de clôture près
de son ranch cet anthropologue est un
spécialiste de la frontière son terrain
est en plein dans la trajectoire du mur
promis par dan trump le docteur sava
l'état voit mal comment il pourra
l'éviter
héloïse apte à metz elle s'est battue
bec et ongles contre les administrations
bush et obama
elle n'a pu arrêter la construction de
cette barrière de métal à quelques
mètres de sa maison
mais elle a surtout obtenu le droit
d'ouvrir le mur pour accéder un
kilomètre plus loin au reste de sa terre
une zone où patrouillent sans arrêt les
gardes-frontières
wall street est coincé entre une clôture
et la frontière avec le mexique
cette femme de 82 ans en veut à l'ex
président obama valdoie ressent la même
frustration vis-à-vis l'administration
trump il a reçu les papiers du
gouvernement lui imposant le passage du
mur sur ces terrains le long du rio
grande et el rass semur demeure celui de
toutes les discordes il divise encore
les gens et les ter et même lorsque la
porte s'ouvre à l'occasion et luisa
tamayo et plusieurs autres laissent
derrière une partie d'eux-mêmes une
parcelle de leur pays bas corner